because i didn't reject him because i  wasn't attracted to him i thought he was  very attractive i rejected him because  he he was like  too much of a [ __ ] so he might have  weakness from you  and so and like three and he'd been just  pursuing me for like years at that point  so i was like oh and maybe he actually  like likes me you know what i mean  because it's been like three years okay  that's a long time to talk about longer  to play was it worth it was the whole  reputation  was the this whole his whole reputation  did live up to the reputation of being a  [ __ ]  nothing happened like that with like no  i mean it ended for um different reasons  but  but that wasn't why like it didn't work  out